when you're setting up playdates for
your daughter
is it uh
is anybody ever like hey man we don't
know dude you're in the weed game
hilarious oh no i'm telling you bro it's
it's a new day um you know i'm a
responsible parent about it anyway you
know it's uh i went drinking wine so i
mean i'm gonna keep bringing it back to
wine uh you know it's all about you know
everything's about context now and so
people really understand it's a it's
it's a burgeoning business man there's
going to be a great fourth of july
celebration in this country one day
once it goes federal
why not
how far out do you see it going federal
ah you know
i don't want to jinx anything but i
i we may not make it out of this decade
i mean yeah what do you call it uh
the uh the the point where the tipping
point the critical mass critical point
of critical seven percent dude freaking
seth
and conan
smoked
on conan's like last show
on basic cable uh-huh knit it up and you
were saying that which got you into the
game is you saw leonardo dicaprio with a
vape pen on nbc and you're like nobody's
saying anything bro i was i was sitting
on my couch leo's sitting there i mean i
got mad respect for leo anyway cause
people don't really respect him for
being an og child actor leo growing
pains everything right so i'm like
gilbert great yeah so i know leo's path
leo's just a guy that got branded
beautiful and he's a good looking dude
but he was always a hardcore character
actor like this dude gets into character
yeah and uh so but you know he and his
crew they get after it and so you know
watching the freaking golden globes
nbc
back after commercial
that was crazy
[Applause]
yeah no i gotta build my brand b i gotta
build my brain
your 12 year old daughter yeah
all of a sudden she says hey dad let me
get some of that purple [ __ ]
she already rocks the hoodie i mean
you got to look at it the same way as as
like you know snoop's kids you know he's
probably got the best litmus test of
somebody growing up in a stoner's
household you know and
calvin to be his i mean
his youngest son is
all of his sons they're they're amazing
they're entrepreneurs they're all over
the place they're they've got they've
got their own booths and complex guns
and they said his daughter
his wife i mean they couldn't be a more
picture-perfect american family you know
it's i'm telling you man like a football
coach yeah he's a freaking football
coach he's got snoops chargers
i mean i'm like you
you know i think that branding is
dangerous man because it can make you
give a perception about something that
that was wrong it was always right i
mean i think the conventional wisdom
would be that hey that's not cool you
know but but there's a lot to be said
for just being upfront with it
communicating about it and not like
sweeping anything under the rug they're
not gonna be some i'm dude my daughter's
gonna drink far before she's 21. okay
she's going to be 16 17 18 years old
with me and if we wanted to taste some
wine i mean that's ordinary in france
she's going to taste some wine sure you
know what happens is i i think and you
can educate me about this i think when
things are made too taboo yeah that's
one of the reasons why where abuses can
come from um as opposed as as opposed to
you know
um um and that's just one of the places
you know because people haven't
we're all battling our own demons you
know what i'm saying yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude